tenemos una función f x graficada aquí y
tenemos varios argumentos sobre el
límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a
distintos valores entonces lo que yo
quiero hacer es averiguar cuál de estos
argumentos cuales son verdaderos y
cuáles son falsos así que vamos a echar
un vistazo al primer argumento el límite
de fx mientras x se aproxima a 1 desde
el lado positivo es igual a 0 es
verdadero es un argumento falso bueno
veamos veamos veamos qué pasa aquí vemos
que mientras x se aproxima a 1 desde el
lado positivo es decir para valores
mayores que 1 entonces mientras x se
aproxima a 1 desde el lado positivo que
es efe x cuando x es por ejemplo un
medio aquí está su f x mientras x se
aproxima más y más a 1 f x está justo
por aquí entonces parece ser que el
límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a 1
desde el lado positivo no es 0 parece
ser que es 1 entonces aquí por lo tanto
éste tiene h este es falso está
este argumento sería verdadero si en
lugar de decir que se aproxima desde el
lado positivo no hubiéramos dicho que se
aproxima del lado negativo
aproximándonos del lado negativo parece
ser que la función si se aproxima al
valor cero si nos aproximamos a uno
desde el lado negativo cuando x está
aquí fx es éste cuando x está acá ftx es
éste cuando x está aquí este es f x y
observamos que el valor de fx parece ser
que se aproxima cada vez más y más a 0
entonces solo es verdad si nos
aproximamos por el lado negativo ahora
siguiente argumento el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a 0 desde el lado
negativo es lo mismo que el límite de fx
mientras aquí se aproxima a 0 del lado
positivo este argumento es verdadero
bueno veamos nuestra fx nuestra función
efe de x mientras nos aproximamos a 0
del lado negativo lo voy a hacer nuestro
color entonces nos aproximamos a 0 desde
el lado negativo este aquí está sub x y
su respectivo valor de fx y tal parece
ser que en la dirección negativa se
aproxima a 1 positivo cuando cuando
ok desde el lado positivo cuando x es
mayor que 0 veamos qué pasa si digamos
que bueno x es un medio
este es nuestro fx si x es un cuarto
este es nuestro f de xy si x está muy
muy próximo a ras del 0 este su f de x
entonces también parece ser que se
aproxima f x igual a 1
este argumento parece ser verdadero y el
límite el límite aquí es 1 esto es
absolutamente verdadero palomita ahora
veamos el siguiente argumento el límite
de fx mientras se extiende a 0 desde la
dirección negativa es igual a 1 esto ya
lo analizamos el límite de fx mientras x
se aproxima desde lado negativo vemos
que nos acercamos más y más cada vez más
a uno mientras x se acerca más y más a
cero f x se acerca a 1 por lo tanto aquí
también tenemos palomita esto es cierto
ahora el límite de fx mientras x tiende
a cero existe bueno en efecto existe ya
lo establecimos que es igual a 1 así que
es cierto eso es cierto ahora el límite
de fx mientras x sea
no existe eso es verdad bueno ya vimos
que mientras nos aproximamos a uno desde
lado positivo el límite parece ser que
se aproxima a uno cierto cuando x es un
medio f x es uno cuando x es un poquito
más que uno fx es uno si parece ser que
nos acercamos cada vez a uno y bueno lo
voy a escribir el límite de fx mientras
se extiende a uno del lado positivo es
igual a uno y bueno ahora cuál es el
límite de fx mientras se extiende a uno
desde el lado negativo aquí este es
nuestro fx para esa equis acá está su
respectiva fx para esa equis ahora
parece ser que está fx se acerca cada
vez más a cero mientras nos aproximamos
a uno desde valores menores que 1
entonces el límite es cero por lo tanto
el límite por la derecha tiene distinto
valor o arroja distinto resultado que el
límite por la izquierda entonces este
límite no existe aquí tenemos tache y
finalmente finalmente el límite de fx
mientras se extiende a 1.5 es igual a 1
hasta aquí lo que hemos observado son
puntos de discontinuidad puntos donde
quizás la función no está bien definida
pero aquí tenemos un punto o simple
sencillo sin más ni más
cuando x es igual a 1.5 aquí está su f
de x esto es f evaluado en 1.5 aquí está
el valor para f de 1.5 lo pongo bien
efe de 1.5 observamos que es igual a 1
aquí la coordenada es 1.5 1 y si nos
aproximamos por el lado izquierdo
también es igual a 1 el límite parece
ser 1 cuando nos aproximamos desde la
derecha el límite parece ser 1 entonces
aquí sale bastante directo la gráfica es
continua en ese punto así que
simplemente observamos la gráfica y el
límite es el valor de la función allí no
no hace falta que tengas una función
indefinida para encontrar el límite en
este caso por lo tanto el límite de fx
mientras se extiende a 1.5 es igual a 1
palomita en este caso